The Bourne Ultimatum was the last film
in the Bourne franchise or so we thought
this one was once again directed by Paul
Greengrass and starred Matt Damon as
Jason Bourne welcome back to my Bourne
series I've been covering every single
Jason Bourne movie leading up to the new
Jason Bourne film I'm skipping the
Bourne Legacy because I reviewed that
back in the day and I don't feel like
re-reviewing it I didn't really enjoy
that movie let's talk about what for
some people myself included is the
favorite Bourne film in the entire
franchise critics and audiences alike
were blown away by this movie it's a
great action film it's a non-stop action
film there is barely a moment to breathe
and even the smaller character scenes
are very exciting and very well acted
and there's not a bit of dialogue that
feels wasted that's one of my favorite
things about the Bourne Ultimatum there
isn't a scene that feels like oh that's
a throwaway scene there's not a pee
break scene there's no scenes like that
even smaller moments where characters
are talking over a meal or something
progressing the plot along it all feels
very vital and you can attribute a lot
of that vitality to Paul Greengrass in
his style
once again this film is directed with
his signature documentary style and it
really works for the Bourne Universe
these films need that kind of style you
could go in a more traditional route but
I really do think that that style is one
of the main reasons these films were so
successful because they do feel a lot
more grounded and realistic despite the
fact that giant big Hollywood moments
are happening right before our eyes
there's something about the way the film
is helmed and especially the editing
that makes it feel so rich as if you're
watching things that are actually
happening and just to let you know just
like my reviews of supremacy and
identity this video is going to contain
some spoilers for the Bourne Ultimatum
if you haven't seen it watch it
you've been warned as I discussed in my
previous Bourne reviews the Bourne
Identity to me is the best character
piece it explores Jason Bourne as a
person very well the Bourne Supremacy
for me is the best thriller because it
is a very much so non-stop thriller but
it's not as action heavy as the Bourne
Ultimatum which is in my opinion the
best action movie of the three largely
because of a white-knuckle sequence in
Tangiers we have a motorbike chase to a
foot chase to a roof
Chace to another chase through various
windows jumping off balconies
culminating in my favorite fight scene
of the entire trilogy that of Bourne
versus desh this is a badass fight it is
edited very fast it is very shaky but it
is a major improvement on a fight scene
in supremacy as I mentioned in my review
for supremacy
I didn't think Greengrass did a very
good job with the fight scene in that
movie here an ultimatum he has perfected
his technique it looks much better it
looks much cleaner and with this style
you either like it or you don't and I
generally hate it I've said this before
in my other reviews especially for the
Bourne films I don't really like
shaky-cam at all I've spoken very
negatively about it in the past
green grass gets a pass might as well
call him Paul green pass very sorry
because in my opinion he does it well
there isn't some attempt to hide poor
stunt work or poor camerawork it's used
as a way to boost the drama of the
moment of the film and him and his
cinematographer craft some really
beautiful moments and the Bourne
Ultimatum is filled with him in
supremacy Joan Allen was looking for
Jason Bourne but she wasn't like Brian
Cox's character she didn't just want to
find him and kill him to erase past
mistakes she wanted to find him to know
the truth and in this film she has yet
another person road blocking her from
that David Strathairn and he is
fantastic in this movie as a ruthless
guy who is after Jason Bourne and will
do anything to find him so this pair
along with some really intense sequences
trying to trap Jason Bourne with
security cameras make the background
action of the movie away from Jason
Bourne just as riveting as those rooftop
chases as those car chases the reason
this movie is my favorite of the three
despite the fact that it doesn't have
quite as much character depth as
identity and it doesn't have as much
exploration of Bourne and his
relationship with Murray that supremacy
had this is the one that just was in
action movie there isn't a forced
romance there isn't some stupid element
that's added to the movie to give it
more drama than it already has it is an
action movie that knows exactly what it
is there is one hint at romance in this
movie and it adds to the drama so well
when he's talking to Julia Stiles
character and he wants to know why she's
helping him
why is she taking pity on him and
there's this little hint that they've
had a past relationship when she says
this it was difficult for me with you
you really don't remember anything
just that one little moment hints that
maybe in the past there was something
between them and he since completely
forgot about that and the reason it
actually adds is because you look back
at identity you see the scene where
Julia Stiles is kind of frightened and
taken aback by born standing there you
look back at their moments in supremacy
where he pinned her down in that
bathroom and nearly killed her and you
add all of this weight to those moments
and it makes the other two films even
better and that's really hard to do for
a sequel to make the other films before
it actually slightly better in small
ways without coming off as a cheap ploy
of some kind and it really works but of
course what you really want in this
movie is some answers
you want some background information you
want to know how he got into this
position as an assassin and the things
you learned through Albert Finney's
character are kind of heartbreaking the
flashback sequences in which you see
Bourne trying to figure out if he wants
to give himself to this program or not
it's some pretty intense shit and you
start to feel even more for this guy but
he's changed so much as a person and
it's such a great story because all the
other people around him are like why are
you acting like this you wanted to do
this this was your idea dude but that's
just not who he is anymore because of
that accident that happened and it makes
for some really entertaining dramatic
moments and the action is just non-stop
whether it's the Waterloo sequence in
which he's trying to lead this reporter
around to keep him away from the cameras
or the sequence where he beats up those
guys and looks and sees one last camera
remaining and goes shit well they caught
me he cut back to the people in the CIA
and they're like fuck something else
that Bourne Ultimatum did that I
actually didn't notice the first time I
saw in theaters is that it takes place
sort of interwoven with supremacy the
first half of it takes place kind of
pushed in the middle of supremacy and
then there's this sequence where he's
talking to Pamela Landy on a rooftop and
after that it takes place after
supremacy a film like this did not have
to do that but they went that route they
tried to enrich the story even more in
fact most people who saw it probably
wouldn't have even noticed unless they
were really looking forward or they're
big fans of the Bourne franchise
Ultimatum has terrific action sequences
a non-stop explosively entertaining
movie another
great performance from Matt Damon and
the entire supporting cast as well as
excellent direction from Paul Greengrass
and another awesome score by John Powell
The Bourne Ultimatum is easily my
favorite er the original trilogy and I'm
gonna give it an A+ I cannot wait for
Jason Bourne that review is coming soon
thank you guys so much as always for
watching and as always
shit
huh
we have your advance ticket for Jason
Bourne we're stuck when I is now bitch